oggi partiremo dall'antichità ma prima
vi chiedo vi è mai capitato di avere
molto bisogno di una risposta e non
sapere a chi chiedere
beh questa è una cosa che sempre
successo e quindi noi vogliamo tornare a
3.000 anni fa e vi chiedo di immaginare
il tempo della grecia antica
immaginate sotto di voi il mare della
grecia dietro di voi c'è il porto con le
barche ormeggiate davanti a voi c'è la
montagna che a metà di questa montagna
c'è un uomo ma chi è quest'uomo dove sta
andando perché sta salendo faticosamente
lui e kadmon è calmo ha un problema come
noi oggi aveva molto bisogno di una
risposta e non sa a chi chiedere a un
vero problema perché sua sorella è stata
rapita da zeus in persona e padre a
genere di tiro che è un re e ordinato di
ritrovarla e lui ci ha provato in tutti
i modi
solo che non c'è riuscito stava per
darsi per vinto
quando si è detto andrò a delfino e lo
chiederò all'oracolo e così termina la
salita è finalmente al cospetto
dell'oracolo ma quel punto dopo avere
interrogato succede una cosa
imprevedibile perché l'oracolo non gli
dici dove si trova la sorella gli dice
carlo scendi dalla montagna la troverai
una mucca
segui la mucca e quando questa si
fermerà la fonderà in una città
il resto è storia perché in effetti da
smog scende dalla montagna trova la
mucca
la segue per un centinaio di chilometri
e quando questa si ferma dopo alcune
peripezie fondo una città non una città
caso fonda la grande città di tebe
c'è da dire che a quei tempi era tutto
più semplice perché quando lei una
grande domanda in mente bastava andare
dall oracolo e interrogarlo
oggi invece è tutto molto più difficile
e sono serviti 2500 anni di storia per
passare da il primo metodo per trovare
delle risposte in modo rigoroso come la
giornata dei greci e poi il metodo
scientifico di galileo fino ai giorni
nostri in cui dobbiamo istruire intere
generazioni di scienziati informatici
ingegneri per costruire delle macchine
per avere delle risposte e come avete
capito sto parlando dei computer che
consultiamo continuamente le nostre
cellulari ma i computer si reggono su un
fondamento molto semplice e rassicurante
questo fondamento è che fanno quello per
cui sono stati programmati quelli della
mia generazione che avevano 10 12 anni
negli anni 80 sono stati forse più
fortunati di chi è nato dopo perché
quando compravano un computer era vuoto
oggi è pieno di app ma all'epoca il
computer aveva un cursore che
lampeggiava avere una macchina che non
faceva niente quindi siamo stati
costretti a imparare a programmare da
soli e programmare è come chiedere a un
tassista parti da questo punto fai
questa strada portami in quel punto e
lui se onesto lo fa ecco se volessimo
fare un paragone con la musica è come la
musica da solista di un flauto
il pentagramma e il programma il flauto
passo dalla prima nota
ne seguì tutte e quando arriva alla fine
solo che di recente negli ultimi anni è
stato inventato un modo nuovo per
programmare i computer che un metodo che
si rifà direttamente a come le
informazioni passa nella corteccia
visiva e questo metodo qualcuno l'avrà
sentito nominare si chiama di planning
ma come fa il di berlin a riconoscere
che questi sono rivolti così come
facciamo noi perché fatta strati e
quindi c'è uno strato più profondo che
gli passa delle informazioni che
derivano da questo stato dove ci sono
dei pattern già combinati che
riconoscono vedete un occhio una bocca
un naso ma queste loro volta venivano
aveva mostrato ancora più profondo dove
ci sono queste battere ancora più
semplice che consentono di costruire
quelli registrati successivi solo che
per una rete di planning e questo è il
bello non importa che queste siano dati
per forza di un immagine può essere dati
di qualsiasi tipo potrebbero essere i
dati della borsa oppure quelli di un
gioco
se vuoi conoscere questo gioco si chiama
go è un gioco antichissimo è un gioco
più complesso ancora degli scacchi
i programmatori di google hanno
programmato una rete di penning per
giocare e finalmente vincere anche
contro le persone
perfino riuscire a vincere contro un
campione del mondo e si racconta che
alla terza partita della serie tra
questo computer è stato di recente è il
campione del mondo il computer abbia
fatto una mossa veramente inconcepibile
per qualsiasi giocatore professionista e
che il commentatore americano vigo
professionale
ha detto di non essersi sentito tanto
bene quando ho visto quella vostra
pensate che il campione del mondo è
uscito dalla stanza da di fronte a 200
telecamere e poi è tornato indietro ha
ripreso a giocare e ho perso quella
partita non sappiamo cosa abbia pensato
quando è uscito però mi ricordo che gary
kasparov quando aveva perso a scacchi
contro di blu aveva detto di essersi
trovato di fronte a un intelligenza
aliena ecco forse non è una grande idea
quella di mettersi contro un
intelligenza artificiale
infatti c'è qualcuno che ha avuto
un'idea migliore cioè quella di
utilizzarla per aiutare i medici a noi
questi pallini neri sullo sfondo rosa
non dicono niente però se date queste
immagini a un medico specialista saprà
dirvi che questi pallini che ci sono a
sinistra sono normali i nuclei di
cellule invece quelli a destra sono
indicazione di un cancro al seno
bene una rete di penning son istruita
per riconoscere questo è poter
coadiuvare un'equipe di medici
ecco ma come fa funzionare questo
procedimento è come se attraverso gli
strati tutte le informazioni
viaggiassero in parallelo
se noi volessimo pensare
no
un paragone
la musica
adesso vogliamo
non c'è
lo strumento
ma concerto
così
a quel punto si deve fare ma fatto di s
sta facendo una cosa come questa oggi
però noi vogliamo andare oltre al noto e
questo noi ancora oltre al noto e quindi
ci facciamo questa domanda è pensabile
mettere una rete di planning in tanti
universi paralleli e in ciascuno di
questi cerca di svolgere il calcolo in
un modo un po diverso
questo è possibile che conseguenze
avrebbe questo diventa un argomento
difficile però oggi cercheremo di farlo
in modo facile devo spiegarvi la
meccanica quantistica in 15 secondi un
pallone da calcio un pallone da calcio
ma voi sapete può girare o in un verso o
nell'altro se cercate di farlo girare in
tutto diverse contemporaneamente starà
ferma ecco ma per gli oggetti molto
piccoli come un atomo un elettrone
funziona ancora così i fisici ci hanno
messo molto tempo per capire questa cosa
però hanno capito un certo punto che è
come se questi aprono in queste cose
molto piccole potessero girare se in un
verso che nell'altro verso ma quando
cercate di farlo girare in due versi
contemporaneamente non fanno più come il
pallone girano in tutte e due versi
contemporaneamente
se non avete capito non preoccupatevi
perché anche einstein ha detto che
nessuno può veramente capire questa cosa
bene va bene però qualcuno si è
domandato ma allora possiamo usare
questa proprietà per fare i computer e
abbiamo visto che i computer sono basati
sui bit
quindi i bit sono le unità di
informazione valgono 10
e invece se usiamo uno di questi beh se
usiamo uno di questi bit quantistici
chiamiamo qubit beh allora in quel caso
potranno valere sia uno che 0
contemporaneamente e questo vuol dire
che per ciascuno di questi pubbliche
aggiungete
le possibilità diventano 2 4 8 16 cioè
anche in questo caso c'è una sorta di
parallelismo nel calcolo però è un
parallelismo quantistico ecco
e allora ci chiediamo ma la teoria
funziona molti me lo chiedono beh sì la
teoria funziona l'abbiamo sviluppata
funziona benissimo e molti mi chiedono
ma in pratica esistono certo i qubit
esistono ci sono dei chip che sono una
dieci cento qubit 500 qubit magari
lavorano a temperature molto basse
però anche per il brano visto restano
così all'inizio c'era uno pochi c'erano
oggi ce ne sono milioni ea cosa serve
bene ad esempio si potranno progettare
nuove molecole per l'agricoltura
risolvere problemi matematici
complicatissime anche questo non ancora
oltre al noto per andare oltre al noto
noi ci chiediamo è possibile mettere una
rete di planning come quella che abbiamo
visto prima in ciascuno degli universi
paralleli che sono creati da questi
qubit alcuni di noi pensano di sì e c'è
una base solida sotto cioè che non c'è
un certo tipo di architettura che già
pre risposto naturalmente permetterci
una rete di planning programmarci da
sopra solo che questa è una rivoluzione
concettuale
perché mentre prima nel caso del deep
learning noi avremmo almeno in via di
principio ho potuto arrivare a capire
come ad esempio nella partita era
arrivata la rete a fare quella certa
mossa proprio in quel certo momento
quella certa partita 15 non è più così
era il sesso motivo per cui non
riusciamo a immaginare un pallone che
gira nei due versi contemporaneamente la
rete di planning realizzerà dei pattern
e tutti sovrapposti contempo
contemporaneamente e
basati su stati di atomi elettroni tutti
mescolati tra di loro e non riusciremo
più a capire come funziona e quindi
lo distingue
fioretto con noi non riusciremo a capire
come funziona questa macchina ma a
questo punto dobbiamo fare una
riflessione e questa riflessione si rifà
un po alla circolarità circolarità della
storia perché siamo partiti da tabù e
cadmo interroga un oracolo che non
capisce di cui non capisce la risposta e
noi ci abbiamo messo 2500 anni per
sviluppare la geometria dei greci il
metodo scientifico di galileo fino a
oggi che mandiamo i satelliti nello
spazio cioè abbiamo un controllo totale
delle leggi della fisica che ci
consentono di fare le cose mirabolanti e
stiamo programmando di realizzare un
oggetto che non capiamo più come
funziona ma insieme a questo processo
c'è stato anche un processo di creazione
di fiducia perché la società ha imparato
a fare affidamento su quello che la
scienza stava realizzando noi andiamo a
fare la risonanza magnetica utilizziamo
i cellulari
ecco ma quindi cosa vuol dire che stiamo
tornando anche da questo punto di vista
all'antica grecia cioè stiamo ritornando
all'epoca dell'oracolo quantistico beh
in realtà ci sono due grandi limiti in
queste macchine e il primo è che le
informazioni che useranno saremo noi a
decidere quali sono e il secondo è che
saremo noi che vorremmo le domande e
solo ponendo delle domande sensate si
potranno avere delle risposte sensate ma
questo vuol dire che la responsabilità
torna nelle mani degli intermediari e
chi sono questi intermediari se non gli
stessi scienziati che oggi stanno
sviluppando queste macchine e quindi
questo vuol dire che si ripristina si
deve ripristinare questo rapporto di
fiducia che c'è tra la società e la
scienza che doveva farsi garante che
disporrà di questi strumenti li
utilizzerà nel modo giusto e quindi
sarà un uomo che dirà alla macchina cosa
è bene e quindi la conclusione che si
saremmo come cadmo davanti all'oracolo
quando lo interrogheremo ma quando
questo ci dirà di seguire una mucca
saremo noi che decideremo se fondare o
meno la nostra tebe grazie